democrats move ahead with their senate
impeachment trial for former president
trump the biden administration and media
push
endless coveted panic in spite of the
science and bidenomics means firing cash
cannons at americans i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
then we're going to get to all the news
of the day in just one moment first a
quick reminder you're spending way too
much money on that cell phone bill like
a lot a lot too much money
on that cell phone bill instead you
should be using pure talk usa over a
thousand of you my extremely wise
listeners
have made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to pure talk
over the past couple of months
what exactly are the rest of you waiting
for if you're with att verizon or
t-mobile your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers
you can even keep your phone and your
number but you will save a fortune by
the way puretalk is the top-rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
with the absolute best customer service
team based right here
in the united states and here's the best
part right now you can get unlimited
talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and here's the thing if
you go over on that data well they're
not going to charge you for it so what
exactly do you have to lose
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
off your very first month dial pound 2 5
0 say keyword ben
shapiro pure talk usa is simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now
so i'll pound it 250 say my name ben
shapiro
for 50 off your very first month okay so
today
the senate of the united states led by
chuck schumer should have been led by
mitch mcconnell but now it's led by
chuck schumer
is going to start the consideration on
the conviction of president trump for
the impeachment charge
that was brought against him by the
house of representatives remember that
single impeachment charge essentially
suggested that trump was responsible for
inciting a riot at the capitol building
on
january 6th that was the main part of
the impeachment charge there were other
ancillary parts like his
earlier call with georgia's secretary of
state brad raffensberger but the main
part of the charge is that he was
personally responsible for the
incitement of the violence that happened
on january 6th now the big problem with
that charge
is really that he is not by any legal
definition responsible for incitement
and it's very difficult to make the
claim that he is responsible for
incitement because of the
colorful language that he used in the
months leading up to january 6th
but that other politicians who use
similarly colorful language are not also
guilty of incitement when violence
breaks out
from people who agree with them this is
the biggest flaw in the entire
democratic argument with regard to
impeachment
now there are some republicans who voted
for impeachment in the house there are
cases that trump had abused his power
that he'd been lying about the results
of the election
that he'd been telling lies about voter
irregularity and voter fraud and
whipping people
into a frenzy and that it was sort of a
foreseeable effect of that that
something bad
would happen but again the wording of
the incitement charge
is pretty specific and beyond that there
is no neutral standard that applies
across the board when it comes to an
impeachable offense on the basis of this
fact pattern and that is the case that
trump's defense is making so we're going
to get to what trump's defense looks
like because that's going to start
rolling out today
the trial actually begins with a
four-hour debate today on the
constitutionality
of bringing an impeachment charge
against a person who is no longer in
office remember
he is former president trump he's not
actually president trump and frankly
if you wanted what was best for the
country i think there's a solid case to
be made that
the country is better off just kind of
moving on and the reason i say that is
not because
trump shouldn't bear the political
consequences of of what he wrought over
the couple of months after the election
i think he is going to bear those
political consequences in whatever way
the american public
sees fitz to bring those consequences i
mean the number one consequence of his
behavior over the past four years is
that he's no longer president of the
united states the simple fact of the
matter is
if he had been as silent on social media
during his presidency as he has been
since he was banned from social media in
the aftermath of january 6th he would
probably still be president
so it's not as though consequences have
not attended to trump's behavior
and the people who actually engaged in
violence those people will be tracked
down those people will be brought to
trial those people will spend time in
jail
as well they should and if democrats are
ever willing to bring forth evidence of
their most outrageous allegations which
is that they're members of congress who
are complicit in the attack
well then members of congress will end
up in jail but when it comes to the
question
of whether it is good for the country as
a broad matter for us to be
relitigating trump's presidency after he
lost an election
in november or whether we ought to be
focused on you know the crises at hand
namely covet
the economy and all the rest i think
that increasingly if
there's a reason both democrats and
republicans want to move fast on this
thing republicans want to move fast on
it because they think that it's
basically just political gamesmanship
which is correct
and democrats want to move fast on this
thing because i think they recognize
that if this drags out for weeks and
weeks
americans are just going to get tired of
it because this is what happens with
virtually every impeachment trial
at the very beginning of the impeachment
trial over ukraine
americans were largely supportive of
impeaching trump by polling data and
then as the thing continued americans
were like
what are we doing again why are we doing
this again what
seriously and you're going to get that
even more now because at least at that
point trump was president
now trump's just some guy golfing in
mar-a-lago so the the idea for most
americans that we should be
expending enormous quantities of time
and not only time by the way cash
you know we're going to spend 500
million taxpayer dollars 500 million
taxpayer dollars to have troops all over
washington dc
during this senate impeachment trial you
know that
now honestly i would love to hear
members of the law enforcement community
explain
just why we need a completely
militarized dc right now
because there's been no violence since
january 6. let's not say there couldn't
be
that's not to say that maybe they don't
have evidence that we haven't seen but
governor desantis in florida governor
abbott in texas they already brought
home their national guard contingent
they're like um we're not seeing
a ton of fomenting violence we're not
seeing giant rallies outside the senate
today so why exactly are we spending 500
million
taxpayer dollars to keep washington dc
in a state of military
lockdown i mean just on the face of it
it's kind of bizarre
so here is how the trial is going to
roll out today according to the hill
senate leadership announced on monday
they've reached a deal on the framework
for former president trump's impeachment
trial
it'll start today for the information of
the senate the republican leader and i
in consultation with both the house
managers and former president trump's
lawyers
have agreed to a bipartisan resolution
to govern the structure and timing of
the impending trial said senate majority
leader chuck schumer
apparently they confirmed on the right
side of the aisle that this was
happening
the timeline would allow the trial to
wrap up as early as next week if both
sides agree
not to call witnesses and this is the
big question right now is whether the
sides are going to call witnesses
under the current deal the senate is
going to debate and vote today on
whether the trial is constitutional
the effort to declare the trial and
constitution will fall short rand paul
foster
forced to vote on this issue late last
month 44 republican senators supported
that particular effort
there are very few republicans who sided
with the idea that it was constitutional
now that was an easy procedural way out
there are some republicans who are
making the case it's not constitutional
to push forward with this tom cotton
from arkansas
is one of those who are senator cotton
explaining the constitutional case
against
convicting a president of an impeachable
offense after he's already left office
i think it's beyond the senate's
constitutional authority to have an
impeachment proceeding
the point of which is to convict and
remove from office a man who left office
three weeks ago
i think it's also a set of misplaced
priorities the democrats continue to
obsess about donald trump
when donald trump left office and went
to florida three weeks ago when the
senate should be focused on things like
how to expand vaccine production and
distribute it more quickly
those are the priorities the american
people want us to focus on not an
inquest into
who is now a private citizen it's an
interesting constitutional debate on the
right side of the aisle basically
the republicans who say that it's
unconstitutional to push forward with
this that's people like tom cotton or
rand paul
their case is that it is an impeachment
trial the purpose of an impeachment
trial is to remove from office a person
who apparently is now already out of
office so what exactly is the point
and on the other side of the aisle there
are people say yes he was impeached in
the house
but the conviction is still part of the
process that happens in the senate
and one of the possibilities is barring
somebody from running for office in the
future
on the basis of a senate conviction so
here's pat toomey who's the republican
senator
from pennsylvania making the opposite
case
you did have um 45
republican senators vote to suggest that
they didn't think it was appropriate to
conduct a trial so
you can infer how likely it is that
those folks will vote to convict
i disagreed with their assessment i
think it is constitutional i think it's
clearly constitutional
to conduct a senate trial with respect
to an impeachment
in this case the impeachment occurred
prior to the president's leaving office
okay so how is this actually going to
roll out the way that this is actually
going to roll out is the opening
arguments then start on wednesday so
under the current deal
the house impeachment managers and
trump's team will have 16 hours over two
days each to present their case
to the senate which is actually a faster
pace than the first trump trial both
sides got 24 hours in that trump trial
at that point chuck schumer was like
we're rushing this thing even now
because mitch mcconnell was in charge
now chuck schumer wants to rush this
thing so much that both sides
get 16 hours to present their case and
you can bet money that if the democrats
start calling witnesses like if they
start calling up aoc to testify
to how terrified she was in the building
that was
you know .3 miles away from the capitol
building protected by police and was
never under assault from writers
if they want to call people like alc
then you can certainly bet republicans
will then call aoc to rebut aoc
and ask her about her own violent
language with regard to republicans and
riots and all of the rest
the way this is going to work is if one
side opens that can of worms with regard
to impeachment witnesses you can bet the
other side certainly will as well
the deal does leave open the door to
calling witnesses
the house impeachment managers
previously invited trump to testify
under oath
his attorneys rejected that because if
you are trump's attorney the last thing
you ever want is donald trump
in a legal proceeding saying anything it
is the worst job in the world being
donald trump's attorney
you can tell because of the churn i mean
seriously that is a bad job because the
first rule of lawyering
is that you get your client to shut up
and then you are the one who is the
mouthpiece for your client
but that is not donald trump's forte is
shutting up
and so being donald trump's lawyer is
always difficult although there are
reports out today that donald trump
shockingly has finally learned that
actually his best pr tactic
may be to not say things apparently he's
like off on the golf courses
and people around him are telling him
you know people are still paying
attention to you and
you using your social media sparingly as
opposed to using it
like you know just word vomit like
that's actually
an effective tactic and trump seems to
have learned that which is why he's
making so few public statements
would to god that he had learned that in
the first year of his presidency
both sides are going to end up with two
hours four closing arguments
chuck schumer says as in previous trials
there will be equal time for senator
questions and for closing arguments
and an opportunity for the senate to
hold deliberations if it so chooses and
then we're going to vote
on the articles of impeachment so that
is the procedure as
it is going to play out in a second
we're going to get to what the content
is likely to be
in the actual senate trial for president
trump on this impeachment charge first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are not getting enough sleep sometimes
you need an extra kick in the butt
in the morning to get yourself going so
i didn't sleep a lot night before last
last night my kids got me up at all
hours my daughter got up at four o'clock
in the morning because she couldn't fall
asleep that means i was exhausted this
morning and then
and then i started drinking my black
rifle coffee kickstart your year
your day and chase your goals with the
most delicious most liberating coffee
known to man we're talking of course
about
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee
company it's a veteran-owned coffee
company
serving premium coffee to people who
love the country
veteran ceo and founder evan hafer spent
over seven years on the ground overseas
with u.s special forces
and as a cia contractor haven't even
modified his gun trucks during the
invasion of iraq to grind coffee
anywhere
brcc is continually committed to
supporting veteran law enforcement and
first responder classes with the
company's buy a bag give a bag campaign
they make sure to give
the gift of america's coffee to people
serving around the globe in 2020 they
donated over 6 million
cups of coffee now the best way to enjoy
black rifle coffee company coffee is
through the coffee club that is a free
subscription where your chosen coffee is
roasted
packaged shipped free to your door on
your schedule in addition to the
convenience you receive special
discounted pricing and
you gain access to exclusive products
member-only content partner discounts
and more you get the freshest coffee in
the country without leaving
the couch i know the dude who run brcc
is a fantastic company and the coffee is
just awesome go to blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro get 20 off your purchase start
your first
coffee club order that is
blackriflecoffee.com
shapiroblackriflecoffee.com shapiro okay
so what exactly is the content likely to
be
well from the democrats what you're
likely to hear is how terrified they
personally were
and also all of their other arguments
which is that the riots were white
supremacy trump is a white supremacist
you're likely to hear about how close we
were to losing our democracy in the
words of representative jackie speier
from california democrat
she says you know we have to hear during
this trial how close we were to losing
our democracy now
let's be frank about this we were not
close to losing our democracy we weren't
i mean we just weren't as a factual
matter
a bunch of yahoos idiot criminal yahoos
evil yahoos running into the capitol
building and putting their feet on nancy
pelosi's desk it's ugly and it's
terrible
and it's bad and it's horrible for the
country that was not us being close to
losing our democracy you know losing a
democracy looks like
it sort of looks like what happens in
countries all over the world when the
military just marches into presidential
palaces and starts arresting officials
right that's what it looks like at no
point was this a coup
a coup is not a bunch of idiots dressed
in buffalo horns
running into a government building and
sitting in somebody's chair that is not
a coup
by the way it's not even a coup if
somebody goes and tries to murder
members of congress
that is an act of evil a criminal act of
eagle okay by the way we've seen it
before
okay it is not even it is not even a
coup when
god forbid a president is assassinated
we've had that in american history
before that's not a coup either a coup
specifically speaking is when one regime
is exchanged
for a more legitimate regime through the
mechanisms of
institutional power generally right
that's when you have the military that
intervenes on the behest of one
political party for example and then aus
a sitting democratic
democratically elected person for
example that is the nature of a coup
this was not a coup
we were not close to losing our
democracy how not close were we to
losing our democracy within hours of
these morons
jumping into the capitol building to
make trouble and videotape themselves
for their for their instagram
congress was back in session ratifying
the election
and making joe biden the president of
the united states so yeah we were not
close to a coup
but again the the lie has what's amazing
is that you don't actually have to do
this i mean seriously democrats don't
have to do this
i said this the day of this could have
been a unifying moment that lies are bad
and people believing lies is really bad
and people then acting on those lies
to do violent and terrible damage is
really really bad we can all be on the
same side of all those questions but
instead it's
well you know donald trump tried to
launch a coup and he he almost he was
barely thwarted no he wasn't
he was not barely 40. you know how i
know he wasn't he wasn't barely thwarted
because on january 20th he didn't attend
the inauguration and joe biden became
president of the united states so that's
how i know he wasn't barely thwarted
it's just the exaggeration is is
unnecessary
and it really does demonstrate that what
this really is about for a lot of folks
as always is the pr right we have a
congress that doesn't actually do
anything for a living we have a congress
that tweets things and goes on cable
news
they're the same job that i do except
that i'm not paid by taxpayer money
nor am i your elected representative
right we have a congress that does not
pass bills we have a congress that does
not negotiate we have a congress that
does
nothing except every once in a while
they vote on some giant omnibus spending
package they toss all power over to the
executive branch a bunch of unelected
bureaucrats govern your life and then
congress goes on twitter
and talks jack about other people that's
that's pretty much what congress does
for a living these days
here's jackie speyer doing just that
again i i there's no wonder why people
hate
the american legislature there's a
reason the legislature does not
legislate
our elected officials do not represent
us all they do
all day long is just yell on cable news
for power it's pretty crazy
i intend like so many of my colleagues
to
put into words that every american
can hear for decades to come how close
we came to losing our democracy
this is a man that intended to overtake
this government and it's astonishing to
me
that so few of my colleagues on the
republican side even after witnessing
that even after being part of that
insurrection are unwilling to do their
jobs
and protect the constitution and protect
the democracy
okay again the democracy was not under
threat okay there were people who were
who were threatening to do bad things
at no point was the institutional
democracy of the united states under
threat
to pretend otherwise is to ignore the
realities on the ground
the military would not have participated
in anything like that republican members
of congress voted to ratify the election
vice president pence was the vice
president under donald trump lest we
forget
he was the person leading the
ratification mitch mcconnell was the
head of the senate
like all of this overwrought hysteria is
in fact overwrought hysteria i'm not
saying it's hysteria
to have been worried or concerned or
freaked out at what happened at the
capitol it is over at hysteria to say
that america was on the brink of turning
into a dictatorship on january 6. that's
just silly
it's silly on its face it's silly in
just a second we're getting to more
silly because again this is really not
about anything to do with trump it's
really just about the the pr that you
can
that you can use in order to foment your
own rise to power in the future via
social media
mainly we'll get to that in just one
second first let us talk
about a way that you can be feeling
better after you go for a workout so
i as you can tell from this god-like
body
i work out incessantly i mean it's a
thing that i love to do and you know
what i get i get a lot of this nagging
muscle pain sometimes joint pain
i'll get cramping or back backaches well
if you are looking to get rid of all
that immediately while providing
yourself with long-lasting recovery
you need to try the natural breakthrough
pain relief solution cryo-freeze sport
roll-on developed by omax health our
friends over at omax they have a new
sport formulation it includes a deeply
penetrating potent punch
of 8.5 of fda approved menthol levels to
instantly ice out and block pain
receptors
reduce inflammation improve muscle and
joint flexibility the best part this 100
natural remedy works its match within
five
minutes of application relief lasts up
to eight hours which is a lot longer
than other over-the-counter products
you're immediately going to feel less
stiffness
and more mobility right now omax health
is offering my listeners 20
off a full bottle of cryofreeze sport
pain relief i'll tell you
i've used this and it does work it
really does work and for me it's made a
big difference the discount also applies
for any product site-wide just go to
omaxhealth.com today enter code ben that
is omaxhealth.com enter code ben to get
off cryofreeze sport and site wide again
it is
great for athletes it's great for active
people people with injuries you've got
nagging problems
you probably qualify somebody who could
use cryofreeze at sport and works within
five minutes of application
and it'll last for eight hours go to
omaxhealth.com enter code ben
to get 20 off cryo-free sport and sight
wide i'm telling you practice the real
deal head on over to omaxhealth.com
enter code ben to get 20
off the entire site alrighty so again
what this trial is really about for the
democrats is ratcheting up the amount of
ire at republicans more generally
which is why you see alexander
ocasio-cortez clinging to the patently
absurd notion that ted cruz tried to
have her murdered
because the goal here is not to
castigate trump for the lies that he
told about the election in the aftermath
of the election
the goal of this is to gastigate all
republicans who she doesn't like
all of them because listen i was not a
fan of what ted cruz did
in objecting to electors but does that
mean that ted cruz was trying to kill
alexander ocasio-cortez of course not
and everybody knows this
the this hysterical nonsense is
hysterical nonsense here's
alexander ocasio-cortez again this is
supposed to be the congress that is
representing us and is going to do the
people's work sure
or alternatively they're just a bunch of
they're just a bunch of complete and
income poops
on social media who are putting out who
are putting out tweets and
and and little videos for laws here
there's no difference between the
memesters who drove up the gamestop
stock and our congress members at this
point
except that the people who are on reddit
are significantly more clever and funny
i think is is basically what i'm coming
away with here here is here's alexander
ocasio-cortez the respected
wonderful congress person from new york
leader of the democratic party
for tweeting that he taught you he tried
to have you murdered a capital
capital right so um that's not the quote
and um and i will not apologize for
what i said i think we're actually done
this morning that's not the quote
that's not the quote that is the exac
that is the quote i mean the actual
tweet that she sent
said that ted cruz tried to have her
murdered at the capitol
i mean come on come on meanwhile ayanna
presley the ringo starr of the squad
she was on national tv suggesting that
january 6 was about white supremacy see
all the narratives get forwarded by
every individual instance
it's it's a thing about politics that
once you see it you can't unsee it and
it's so irritating
it's really just a point of high
irritation there are a bunch of preset
narratives
facts very often do not fit into those
narratives and
most people are unwilling to shift their
narrative even after the facts disprove
the narrative
january 6th there is so little evidence
that it had anything to do with race
like seriously is there what is the
evidence that it had to do with
race specifically as opposed to being
about people who were just pissed that
trump had lost
the election for a wide variety of
reasons and yet somehow it was about
white supremacy to ayanna presley
because she thinks literally everything
on earth fits into the white supremacy
narrative
student loan that student loan issues
those are a white supremacy narrative
housing it's about white supremacy and
of course january 6th about white
supremacy
when everything is about white supremacy
then you have now bought into a false
narrative and you are using that false
narrative as a cudgel to wield against
your political enemies which is ugly
stuff here's iona presley doing that
as a black woman to be barricaded in my
office
using office furniture and water bottles
on the ground
in the dark that terror
those moments of terror is
familiar in a deep and ancestral way for
me
and i want us to do everything to ensure
that a breach like this never occurs at
the capitol
but i want us to address the evil and
scourge that is white supremacy in this
nation
the hell is she talking about i mean
really what the hell is she talking
about
the majority of members of congress are
white
the majority of them are white they were
also hiding in their in they're mitch
mcconnell
is the whitest person to ever white
mitch mcconnell was hiding in his office
all of this stuff is it's so stupid our
politics is just so stupid i've like run
out of patience with the stupidity of
our politics
it's unreal how stupid our politics is
okay so trump's response to all of this
is a very long trial my miranda 78-page
trial memorandum
talking about the charges against him
it's sort of a mix
of decent argumentation together with a
bunch of trumpian flourishes because if
trump looks because of course trump is
going to look over the final document
and so it references trump's arrangement
syndrome on like the very first page of
the trial memorandum what trump's team
understands
is that this is all just a pr effort
that the the
trial is not about holding him legally
responsible he is not going to be held
legally responsible via conviction in
the senate it's just not going to happen
they don't have the votes and everybody
knows it
so that means that trump's team is
basically going to present the
countervailing case
and the countervailing case according to
the memorandum is pretty obvious which
is
trump didn't incite anything on january
6th that by all available evidence the
action was pre-planned
which is correct by the way right
virtually everyone has already reported
that the this that this was pre-planned
apparently you know the democrats had
started their impeachment effort before
they even conducted an investigation
that during the actual during the actual
rally before the riots
trump talked about peacefully protesting
at the capitol building that the riots
started in the middle of his speech
right they didn't actually start after
his speech it wasn't like he finished
and then they went over
they started in the middle of the speech
now critics are saying oh yeah he'd
already said the inflammatory part
all right but he called for peaceful
protest in the speech i know we're all
trying to avoid that but that happens to
be a fact
okay it's on tape and they are correct
law enforcement had reports of a
potential attack on the capital several
days
before trump's speech itself which
suggests that it was not the speech that
actually triggered the violence events
of january 6th
you can say that trump's rhetoric
contributed to the attitude of the
people who stormed the capitol but if
the
if the argument is incitement that means
that you incited the violence with the
speech of january 6th
that's the impeachment charge okay so
all of those are fairly good defenses
and those will be
brought to bear democrats the the more
rabid democrats are saying that they
want to bring witnesses
i think they're unlikely to do so
they're going to get what they want to
get out of this thing they'll get all
the headlines they want and then
we'll all move on but does this have
anything to do in reality
like making the country a better place
at this point no trump's out of office
presumably he will remain out of office
and all democrats are doing the real
reason they're focusing on trump because
they don't want him to go away that's
the reality
democrats in the media do not want trump
to go away they want trump there so they
can use him as a foil without trump
there is a foil they have to find some
other republican like marjorie taylor
green
a first-term backbencher from georgia
that they can use as the face of all
republican evil
so they're going to try and keep this
alive as long as possible the american
people are bored with it and i think
they're going to want to move on
asap okay in just one second we are
going to get to everything
covid related because the team of
science ain't following the science
first
let us talk about the simple fact that
you value your hair i know you do
i value my hair too and now there is a
one-stop shop for hair loss and wellness
in men
it's time to write a new chapter one in
which you actually have hair thanks to
science baldness can now be optional
hymns is helping guys be the best
version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and
fda approved products to help treat hair
loss we're not talking about like snake
oil pills or gas station counter
supplements
these are prescription solutions backed
by science hymns was created by a dude
who knows
some men's health conversations are
easier online than in person no more
awkward in-person doctors visits or long
pharmacy lines for hymns
connects you to licensed medical
professionals online it could save you
hours
completely confidential it's discreet
you answer a few quick questions and
medical professional reviews
and then if they determine it's right
for you they can prescribe your
medication to treat hair loss it's
shipped directly
to your door today hymns is giving you
their best offer yet if you're not happy
with your results after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund right
now my listeners can get their first
visit absolutely free
head on over to for hymns dot com slash
ben that is for hims.com
ben prescription products require an
online consultation with a healthcare
provider who'll determine
if a prescription is appropriate
restrictions do apply
see website for full details and
important safety information remember
that is
for hymns.com for hims.com
and get your first visit absolutely free
and get those issues worked out
including baldness go check it out right
now for hims.com
okay so meanwhile the coveted numbers in
the united states are actually getting
significantly better
coveted cases are now at their lowest
level since october which is definitely
a good thing they've dropped
precipitously
since the beginning of the year when it
comes to deaths deaths are also
startling
starting to level off in the united
states and drop
some of that is due to vaccination a lot
of that is due to the fact that we've
seen this pattern before basically
you have variants of covid or or waves
of covet
they burn through a community they run
out of people to burn through and then
they and then they wane so hopefully by
the time
we move forward with this thing by the
time the next variant hits a lot of
people are vaccinated
that'd be great and we are rolling out
vaccines at a fast pace and that is
largely thanks to the trump
administration
which the biden administration has
denied over and over and over again
and yet we are still hearing this sort
of panic to tone from our media it's all
panic
all day all the time from our media
because there has to be some bogeyman
that team biden can use in order to jack
through their agenda
right to understand that the biden team
when it comes to their economic plans
those economic plans are not in a vacuum
popular
if it were not for the for for covid
first of all trump probably would have
been re-elected if it were not for covet
the economy was just too good but
if it were not for cove do you think
americans would be on board with
spending 1.9
trillion dollars with a.t do you think
americans would be on board with a 15
national minimum wage which is more than
significant percentages of people in
less wealthy states earned
like did you think that that's do you
think that makes a lot of sense people
would not be up for this
a lot of the biden agenda rests on the
specter of covid in the in the
background
and so they're going to continue to play
this thing up and they will do so in
hypocritical fashion it'll be the media
and the democratic party doing this
and so you'll end up with a cnn reporter
looking at tampa
and i was down in tampa or up in tampa
rather uh for for the super bowl
and there were a lot of people who were
unmasked in tampa
i mean that is true it is also true that
in the actual super bowl stadium because
you had to everybody was
masked up but these cnn reporters are
very selective and when they get
outraged about lack of masks
if it's happening in new york they're
really not all that concerned about it
if it's happening in florida they are
super concerned about it despite the
fact that florida has performed
admirably given the fact that florida
has by far the oldest population in
america
not close but here is a cnn reporter
absolutely aghast at the fact that there
are young people who are healthy
not wearing masks in tampa let me show
you a scene from
last night in an area called ebor
city we have some video to show you you
can see
on the streets of ebore city this
massive crowd
again not many of them wearing a mask
this is a very popular spot where
people go to bars and restaurants there
were some police there
but we're unsure about citations i spoke
to the tampa police and i asked them
what are you doing about this because a
lot of people
were very concerned okay there's one
thing that you will notice
primarily above all uh in these crowds
there's not a person over 30.
i mean if you look at these pictures you
cannot spot a person over the age of 30
years old in these in these pictures
so the the very basic notion that this
poses like a massive health risk
to the united states because a bunch of
25 year olds are walking around without
masks 25 year olds are not dying of
covet
so unless they're going home and they're
infecting granny this really is not a
huge
issue frankly because again 25 year olds
not dying of covet
nonetheless this drove tampa when i say
not like
in massive numbers or in outsized
numbers just to be very specific for the
idiot fact checkers who don't understand
the english language or how it works
okay the reality is there are a few
people who are 25 who will die of covet
it is
vastly disproportionate to the actual
number of people who are at risk from
covet
okay here is tampa's mayor jane castor
she saw the cnn report obviously and now
she's like
everybody who's masterless at the super
bowl is going to be identified by law
enforcement yes this sounds like a
a tremendous use of resources my
favorite part of this is the cop
standing directly behind her
who's got the mask on under his nose you
know we
we had tens of thousands of people all
over the city downtown out by the
stadium
ybor city uh down here in channel side
and very very few incidents
so i'm proud of our community but
those few bad actors will be identified
and the tampa police department will
handle it now the media want to sort of
have it both ways
because one of the things that has been
happening and it is a reality is that
populations mask up or associate at
different rates so you've seen
that the media are very very down on
orthodox jews in new york
and new jersey right they've been very
down on them since the beginning of the
pandemic and
i think there's some justifications the
idea that if you're getting together in
closed spaces without masks
and then you're transmitting the virus
at high rates that has to do with
personal behavior
but the media completely ignore that
when it comes to people who are also
getting
the virus at disproportionate rates at
no point have they suggested for example
that disproportionate rates of covid
in the black community in new york which
is a thing then maybe that has to do
with personal behavior as well right
it's either it's either personal
behavior or systemic racism for each
but the way that it works is if a bunch
of jews get in new york that is called
personal behavior and if a bunch of
black folks get it in new york then it
is all about
systemic racism is the way that this
works well now you have the new york
times justifying black people refusing
to get the vaccine
now if this were a bunch of white people
refusing to get the vaccine it would be
about q anon
and trump support right but charles blow
over the new york times has an entire
piece
about why it is that many black
americans are not getting the vaccine
and
he's attempting to justify or excuse it
which is crazy
okay because the people who need the
vaccine the most presumably are the
people who are getting it at the highest
rates this is what we have been told and
the people getting it that are
getting it at the highest rate are
people of color in the united states
so why would you be making excuses for
people opting out of that
but that's that's exactly this is like
the fifth editorial from the new york
times making this case
he he says that black americans are
justified in not getting the vaccine
because they don't trust the government
which is a weird way for that that's a
weird argument given
that black americans are voting in a 92
to 8 clip
for a party that wants to expand the
size scope and reach of government
if you don't trust the government it
seems like a weird indicator how much
you distrust the government to vote for
the party that vows to expand it in
every area of your life
but in any case here's what charles blow
says he says the distrust in the
healthcare system
is real in the black community perhaps
most notably at least in the last
century
was the tuskegee experiments in which
hundreds of black men were told they
were being treated for syphilis when in
fact they were not
they were being observed to see how the
disease would progress those men
suffered from under this experiment for
40 years yes it happened in the 1930s
30s okay the the people today who are
denying vaccines and are 30 years old
their grandparents were not alive when
the tuskegee experiments happened
the associated press exposed the program
in 1972 but the black people in the age
group most resistant to the vaccine
weren't alive when that experiment was
conducted as charles's blood knowledges
indeed
older men those who might have been
alive at that time are more likely to
want the vaccine
yes because they're the people who are
most vulnerable to kovid generally
he says it occurs to me something bigger
might be contributing to those numbers
and overall mistrust of a government
that has repeatedly disappointed
disrespected and dehumanized black
people
ah so when black americans refuse to get
the vaccine then it's because of
justified
distrust of the government from
population that overwhelmingly votes for
the party of government
when white people refuse to get the
vaccine it's because they are doing
something dumb
the the media double standard is pretty
amazing there it's pretty amazing
okay meanwhile the biden administration
continues to ratchet up it's a one-way
ratchet
in terms of how worried we're supposed
to be we're never supposed to get less
worried we're always supposed to get
more worried
so now we have anthony fauci saying that
when he was asked
by bret bear so when can the masks come
off
like you know we're now rolling out
these vaccines over a million a day
people are getting the shot when can the
when can the masks come off
fauchi's answer is so bizarre and
disturbing here it is
if we can get and i have used this as an
estimate it's not definitive
that if we can get 70 to 85 percent of
our population
vaccinated and get to what we would hope
would be to a degree
of hurt immunity which really is an
umbrella or uh
or a veil of protection against the
community where the level of virus is so
low it's not a threat at all then at
that point you could start thinking in
terms of not having to have uniform
wearing of mass okay it's that last it's
that last sentence that's insane
when the virus the risk of it does not
exist
then you can take off the mask okay so
when we have learned to defeat death
generally you can leave your house when
the risk of the virus
does not exist are you out of your
damned mind we've shut down the entire
world economy
for a year for a disease that mainly
kills people over the age of 70.
and you can make the argument that
that's a good idea you can make the
argument that's a bad idea i'll tell you
what is an absolute crap idiotic
anti-scientific idea the idea that the
virus is going to have a zero percent
risk rate a zero percent risk rate and
that's when you can take off the mask
you know when people are gonna take off
the masks seriously people are gonna
take off the masks after they get the
shots it is that simple on a practical
level
once people have the shots they're going
to say i am done with this and i'm
taking off the mask
and i'm not gonna stay away from grandma
i'm not going to stay away from parties
i want to go to
if grandma's at a particular risk like a
super high risk maybe if i'm really
worried i might stay away
but generally speaking people have to
live their lives and this idea that we
live in a bubble where risk does not
exist
and the risk from covet is going to go
down to zero before we all start taking
off our mass
nut nuts it's not going to happen i mean
you can see what's happening in tampa
right now
people who don't believe their risk are
not wearing masks people who believe
they are at risk
are wearing masks people who believe
they are at risk are getting vaccinated
people who believe they're not at risk
are not getting vaccinated
turns out people have individual
judgment but this notion that we're
going to cram down mass scoring on
people
until the end of time when the risk is
zero is insane
it's insane and by the way counts are
productive because
if i have to wear a mask forever why
would i bother getting vaccinated
seriously i'm 37 i'm healthy why bother
getting vaccinated
if i have to wear a mask forever and the
mask is supposed to protect the people
around me from the risk of transmission
i can just skip the shot and wear the
mask if we're all going to be wearing
masks until the end of time anyway
it's it's it's idiotic pr it is
anti-scientific it is ridiculous
and this guy is the greatest doctor in
the land oh i'm sorry he's the second
greatest doctor in the land we also
heard
from the very very scientific dr joe
biden the greatest of all doctors
it goes in order doctor like from from
least great doctor to greatest doctor
it goes like jonas salk dr pepper
dr j dr fauci dr jill biden
who has a doctorate in education from
the prestigious university of delaware
after writing a dissertation
about the importance of junior college
here is dr joe biden informing you
how you should live your life when it
comes to masking
hi there i'm julie i'm here at the white
house with our two dogs
champ and major for a lot of us during
this pandemic
our pets have been such a source of joy
and comfort
and maybe a bark or two on a video
conference the unconditional love from a
dog is one of the most
beautiful things on earth and we owe it
to them to keep ourselves healthy so
please keep wearing your masks even when
you're
out walking your dog right guys
[Music]
uh by the way if you're walking your dog
away from people don't wear your mask
seriously if you're if you're 100 feet
from somebody and you're walking along
on a on a park path and you're wearing a
mask
i don't know why you are there's no
purpose to it but dr jill says so and i
have been informed that she's the
greatest of all doctors
and on the list of doctors she is the
top doctor like in all of human history
like she she's a she's a more important
figure in medical history than
hippocrates
just unbelievable importance
oh the science the science we'll get to
more of
science in just one second first let us
talk about the fact now is not a great
time to go to the auto parts store in
fact you know it's a great time to go to
the auto parts store never
because you wait in line for a really
long time then you get to the front and
then you
are having to answer a bunch of very
specific questions about your car you
probably don't know the answers to
finally you tell them what part you need
and they're like you know what why don't
we order that online for you and then
upcharge you
or you could just order it online
yourself and not pay the upcharge by
going to rockauto.com rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based
on what the market will bear like
airlines do why spend up to twice as
much for the same parts
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts the rockauto.com catalog
is unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and write shapiro
in there how did you hear about xbox so
they know that we sent you helps them
helps us go check them out rockauto.com
write shapiro in there how did you hear
about xbox when you
check out alrighty so here's the thing
folks you've heard me talk about our
all-access membership before
but for those of you who have not heard
me talk about it it is our most
elite membership base here at the daily
wire our all access members
receive two leftist tiers tumblers when
they sign up being an all-access member
means you get to watch full coverage of
all daily wear shows not to mention our
feature film
and soon to be coming entertainment
content what's more
you get to tune into exclusive all
access live that's a show featuring a
different daily wire host every single
day where all access members can chat
with us in the chat box tonight for
example
you can chat with me personally people
love it
it is fun it is a kick we basically just
hang out for an hour i answer all your
most intelligent and also stupidest
questions i do impressions i sing songs
i tell stories about my kids
today we want to publicly thank all of
our all access members for their
commitment to the daily wire to show our
appreciation
we are mailing out this check this baby
out
we're mailing this special anniversary
tumbler for all renewing
all access members this year so you
already have a membership but you want
to renew now would be the time to do you
get this look at that it's beautiful
it's red and it has
our statement of principles on the back
it's got our signatures
on the back michael knowles looks like
he writes like a child
but everybody else's signature is really
really nice mine's up top
of course go check out our commemorative
leftist
tiers tumbler you can add that to the to
your cabinet you can give it to a friend
this is a commemorative part of our
five-year journey journey and a thank
you to our all-access members in
particular for supporting
who we are and what we do you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation so that biden administration
really big
on the science speaking of which is joe
biden with us we always have to ask this
because
usually he's kind of not like they can
kind of
get him up and wheel him around weaken a
bernie style for like a short period of
time before he uh before he starts to
babble mountains
so yesterday he was on a covet call with
a registered nurse
and he creepily started babbling about
how young she looked which by the way if
donald trump had done that endless
headlines about his sexism and all the
rest but joe biden doesn't he's just a
charming older fellow
here was here was joe biden saying weird
things
about a registered nurse they know that
i'm trying to do
everything to make this safe and
efficient
so support yeah
are you a freshman at the university no
no you look like a freshman
[Laughter]
she's been a registered nurse for nine
years she's probably 30. so no she does
not look like a 17 year old girl
joe biden you weirdo you big old weirdo
we only elect weird people to be
president now it's just a thing this is
a thing
murica well speaking of the uh the party
of science and the biden
administration's party of science
so um i'm just gonna note here so
biden's cdc director
right she came out yesterday and she
said you know when when donald trump was
president
he there were a few minori there there
are a few coveted guidelines minority of
code guidelines
that were politically impacted rashel
walensky
said that anne schuchat the cdc's
principal deputy director and career
civil servant
is in charge of the review of those
regulations she said a vast minority of
the public health agency's guidelines on
how the nation should respond to the
coronavirus pandemic
have been quote unquote politically
swayed by former president donald
trump's appointees and that the agency
is in the process of updating those so
the headline became
biden's cdc director says that a
minority of coveted guidelines were
politically swayed
i'll just remind you that this week joe
biden
completely undercut his own cdc director
because she said schools can reopen
without teachers being vaccinated
and then jen sackey the white house
press secretary was like well she was
just speaking in her personal capacity
obviously politics no longer matter when
it comes to the cdc they are just
following
to science speaking of which nora
o'donnell did ask joe biden over the
last couple of days
why exactly are the schools closed at
this point and joe biden did not have a
good answer
about 20 million american children
have not been in the classroom for
nearly a year
there's a mental health crisis happening
it really is
women are dropping out of the workforce
is this a national emergency
it is a national emergency it generally
is a national emergency
okay so it's a national emergency but
joe biden i have a question if it's such
a national emergency when are we gonna
reopen
well the answer is we're going to reopen
when the teachers unions
say that we can reopen because joe biden
does not run his own administration do
you think it's time for schools to
reopen
i think it's time for schools to reopen
safely
safely you have to have fewer people in
the classroom
you have to have ventilation systems
that have been reworked
our cdc commissioner is going to be
coming out with science-based judgment
within i think as early as wednesday as
the layout what the minimum requirements
are
really you guys didn't have this ready
like months ago i was informed over the
party of science
by the way the trump administration did
have reopening guidelines
for schools they did exist so i don't
know the hell you guys are talking about
schools in florida they never closed
schools in europe
many of those never closed schools in
israel largely never closed
all over all over the world particularly
for elementary school children
there the risk of transmission in
elementary schools
is extraordinarily low very very low and
yet here you still have this guy because
he's in hot to the teachers unions
pretending that he's speaking on behalf
of the science it's just a lie
who's he really speaking on behalf of
randy weingarten and the american
federation of teachers
there are a lot of great teachers out
there teachers who want to be in school
teachers who are doing a great job for
kids and then there are the teachers
unions which are bags of flaming garbage
and should be illegal if they are
publicly if they are public sector
unions they should be illegal
it is ridiculous the teachers are
allowed to bargain against the interests
of students and taxpayers
and and the fat cats at the top were
earning million dollar salaries and
building giant monuments themselves in
washington dc
in order to prevent children from
learning are doing nobody any favors
the new york times nonetheless has a has
a sop piece
on randy weingarten from uh from just
the other day
from yesterday talking about how she is
going to work with joe biden to reopen
schools
randy weingarten yes sure she is
teachers said miss weingarten have good
reasons to be anxious
they don't trust soap and running water
will always be available in schools
because sometimes they haven't been they
don't trust that extra funding will
materialize for masks hand sanitizer and
nurses because in so many other years
budgets were cut
oh probably it's that it can't just be
that these unions are taking advantage
of a really bad situation
in order to bargain for more things by
the way undercutting the demand for
their services
the number of people who are opting for
homeschooling is at record rates record
rates
but one of the things that we have to
understand about what is going on right
now
is that in order to gin up panic ginning
up panic about covet is largely at this
point
when vaccines are right around the
corner for millions of americans
millions of americans already had them
ginning up panic is all about pushing
the concomitant political agenda
more power to the teachers unions and
more spending
so you've got jen sackey over at the
white house saying it's time to roll out
these giant economic plans 1.9 trillion
dollars in stimulus
now again recognize that by most
economic standards people believe that
the economic spending shortfall due to
covet this year is going to be about 400
450 billion dollars
so they're spending about four times
that amount of money in order to quote
unquote rectify the breach
okay and in order to do this they're now
claiming that they also want to kill a
bunch of jobs
so jen sackey was specifically asked
about fossil fuel workers because
one of the things that joe biden has
been pushing in the middle of a pandemic
his new restrictions on fossil fuel
development and fracking
and jen sackey was asked about that she
was asked okay so you want a bunch of
people keystone xl you want a bunch of
people to lose their jobs in the middle
of a pandemic
and her answer was how dare you sir
so much how refreshing so much
transparency and factual
accuracy coming from jen sackey when is
it that the
administration is gonna let the
thousands of
uh fossil fuel industry workers whether
it's pipeline workers or construction
workers
who are either out of work or will soon
be out of work because of a vitamin eo
when it is and where it is that they can
go for their green job
and that is something the administration
has promised there is now
a gap so i'm just curious when that
happens when those people can count on
that
well i'd certainly welcome you to
present your data of all the thousands
and thousands of people who
uh won't be getting a green job maybe
next time you're here you can present
that
what the hell does that mean well
seriously what
he's asking you that's the question lady
can you show anybody who's gotten a
green job because you keep saying that
when somebody is laid off from a
fracking job when somebody loses their
job in the keystone xl pipeline don't
worry they'll get a green job
and ducey's like okay so can you name
them like who got a green job and she's
like maybe you can tell me who got a
green job
what i i mean i can tell you all the
people who just lost their jobs at
keystone xl
we can look up their names and we can
ask them if they are now working on
windmills that is a possibility
okay but that's not the only great biden
economic plan that is going to be
propped on the back of covid she says
that joe biden wants to make sure that
in this 1.9 trillion dollar package
the national minimum wage is raised to
15 where they come up with 15 bucks
out of shamasa wants but okay sean mason
is a socialist from seattle she's been
preaching 15
minimum wage in seattle seattle you may
have noticed is not birmingham alabama
in fact they are two very very different
places and 15 minimum wage
drove a lot of small businesses out of
business in seattle here is jen saki
however saying it is vital in the middle
of a pandemic
with with unemployment at extraordinary
rates for us to raise the minimum wage
to throw people out of work and create
lower margins for businesses to operate
brilliant brilliant stuff
the president is remains firmly
committed to
raising the minimum wage to 15 that's
why he put it in his first legislative
proposal and he doesn't
he believes in any american who is
working a full-time job
trying to make ends meet should not be
at the poverty level and it's important
to him
uh that the minimum wage uh is raised
okay by the way just legislating that
somebody be paid more money does not
mean that they will actually be paid
more money
many of those people their minimum wage
will now be zero because they will be
laid off or
people are just gonna put a bunch of
self-checkout lines in grocery stores
which is what kroger is going to do
they're now experimenting with getting
rid of all checkout specialists like all
of them
and they're just gonna put machines in
place by the way if you're not worried
about any of this
anthony pompliano the investor he
tweeted out within the last 12 months
we've increased the us dollar supply by
40 by 40
there will be consequences for that sort
of stuff
okay meanwhile the culture wars continue
a pace so if you think that things
weren't falling apart fast enough the
culture wars
definitely continue a pace the new york
times is very angry at the super bowl
so every every time there's a super bowl
and the super bowl is not
sufficiently woke people get super
ticked off so ken belson has a long
piece of the new york times about the
evils of the super bowl he says the nfl
likes to project power and precision
sideline catches are scrutinized with
zoom lenses first downs are measured in
inches
air force jets fly over stadiums just as
the star-spangled banner reaches its
peak
but when it comes to topics like race
health and safety
the league's certainty dissolves into a
series of mixed messages
that was the case on sunday at the super
bowl the nfl's crowning game
typically watched by about 100 million
viewers in the united states
the championship game provides the
league a massive platform each year to
promote itself as america's corporate
do-gooder with the best interests of its
enormous fan base
at heart that was harder to do this year
on sunday the nfl trumpeted its support
for the fight against social injustice
the national anthem was performed by two
musicians one black and one white the
poet amanda gorman who wowed the country
with her recitation and president
biden's inauguration
read an ode to three honorary captains
it was it was fine
i was there and i was like uh okay the
tv announcer spoke often of the work
that the league and players have done to
battle racial inequities yet
moments later says the new york times
when the kansas city chiefs took the
field
the nfl played a recording in the
reduced capacity stadium of the made-up
war cry
that is a team custom the prompts got
fans to swing their arms in a tomahawk
chop an act
many find disrespectful and a
perpetuation of racist stereotypes of
the nation's
first people wow i mean just the
brutality of the nfl
brutal plus no one mentioned colin
kaepernick which i mean frankly i have
to admit
like matt walsh i was appalled that no
one mentioned colin kaepernick because
yes tom brady cemented his status as the
greatest quarterback ever to play
football
but he was the second greatest
quarterback to ever play football
because we all know
that the true greatest is the person who
has been denied a slot in the nfl for
years after backing up the immoral
blaine gabbard
in san francisco colin kaepernick we
needed more colin kaepernick talk
we needed more of that i mean after all
mariah carey did tweet out happy colin
kaepernick appreciation day
there was no talks as the new york times
of the lee's abysmal record hiring
people of color
as head coaches and general managers or
even as television cameras showed that
she's successful offensive coordinator
eric
binemy who is black and been unable to
land a head coaching position in
multiple hiring cycles
before the game cbs sports showed a
segment that featured viola davis
saluting kenny washington a black player
who in 1946 reintegrated the nfl which
had an unofficial color barrier for 13
years but
there was no discussion of a loss you
brought by two former nfl players who
accused the league of rigging the
concussion settlement
well i mean that probably that's what
they should have led with at the super
bowl you know as a piece of marketing
probably should have led with also were
secret races
i will say the nfl did its best to buy
into woke
nonsense so the nfl ran a commercial
after the end of the
after the end of the um super bowl in
which
it just basically poured out a bunch of
woke slogans
so it showed one of the referees one of
the female referees wearing a hat that
said end racism that hat by the way did
end racism
well in the history books it will go
down that in 2021 racism was ended
by the hat of an nfl referee so lots of
racism being ended right here
here is the nfl ad promising to en they
promised they were going to spend 250
million dollars to end systemic racism
250 million systemic racism what an
amazing contribution by the nfl
in fact i think the nfl has contributed
hundreds of millions of dollars to quote
unquote ending systemic racism
considering
a huge percentage of the league's
players are black and people in the
league are being paid an exorbitant
amount of money far above the average
american
so that seems like that's a good way to
end systemic racism nonetheless here was
the nfl pledging to do more because
corporate wokeness is now a thing gang
to fulfill the promise of one nation
to be part of the solution
be part of the change to try harder
show up dive in
and stay at it
[Music]
wow amazing amazing by the way i'll tell
you what is true
in this and they've got people kneeling
and say while the season is over
well the season is over the fight isn't
oh yes
yes and it's got people raising the
black power fist and all this
okay um our fight for social justice is
not so in any case
the nfl is doing its best to do the
corporate wilderness routine but nothing
is enough
for the new york times here's the
reality the reason people watch the
super bowl for many many many people
including me
the only game i watched all season was
the super bowl and maybe they did the
wokeness routine in the commercials i
can tell you in the stadium it was not
really a thing
in the stadium the nfl really did not
play that stuff up and they didn't play
that stuff up
because guess what when you call the
american system systemically racist and
suggest that america is a deeply
offensive place
and suggest that nfl players are
victimized by systemic racism on a
regular basis
most people sense the bull crap in that
yet the the culture wars continue
apace meanwhile google is running ads
you want to talk about systemic racism
google is now running ads
touting their ability to search for
black owned businesses
now imagine for just a second that
google touted the ability to search
for white owned businesses do you think
that'd be something they'd be
championing
i'm seeing this on amazon also right now
if you go to amazon they will try to
link you to black owned businesses
because it's black history month
that's racist just in its purest form it
is racist to suggest that you should
shop at a business because of the skin
color of his owner
that is a racist thing and yet this is
something that all of corporate america
is now buying into including
the social media bros who are who are
disseminating their own information
and policing how dissemination of
information actually works here was
google's ad
touting the fact that you can now search
for who owns a business by race
unironically believing that they are
fighting racism in the process
somebody typing in black owned
restaurant memphis
oh look at that it popped up
the four-way is a destination place
right here between these walls is a lot
of history to have a place
where you have dignity and belong
that's the legacy of the four-way
identifies as black on i do like
identifies as black owned
is what pops up because that means
they're not actually checking
right that's what it means when they say
identify not black owned identifies as
black
owned means that somebody checked that
box that it's a black owned business um
but i also love the implication which is
that black owned businesses are a place
where black people belong
but apparently white owned businesses
are not i mean that's what's said in
that
in that commercial and this is what you
saw during the blm riots by the way as
you saw people
we saw in l.a we saw people who were
boarding up their businesses and
writing on the on the plywood black
owned business
which is the most racist passover story
ever basically
i was like oh maybe they will pass over
my store if i just write black owned
business on the front of the store
they're only going to target people who
are not of a particular race the fact
that corporate america
has like where's the unit is this unity
really is that unity
i think people should patronize black
owned businesses and white owned
businesses and asian owned businesses in
fact i think people should patronize all
of the businesses that they think are
good
that's pretty much it that is my is that
standard terrible it seems like a pretty
good standard to me
and yet we have an entire corporate
infrastructure that is devoted to the
idea
of a racial segregation that we were
supposed to abhor
and should abhor pretty impressive stuff
meanwhile turmoil continues inside the
newsroom over at the new york times a
great piece over at the washington free
beacon
by aaron siberium uh we talked yesterday
about this story from the new york times
when you talk about the complete
takeover of institutions by the woke
culture
the new york times has been taken over
it's been destroyed nicole hannah jones
is the de facto editor over there as i
said yesterday nicole
hannah jones is not a journalist she's
an activist and she's a bad person and
nicole hannah jones
basically just got a man fired for
having said the n-word
in the context of explaining a story in
which the n-word was the key part
by the way she has tweeted out using the
n-word before herself
right in discussing a story as we'll see
so aaron siberia writes this over at the
washington free beacon
the resignation of star new york times
science writers john mcneil jr
has sparked a furious back and forth
among time staffers
many of whom are outraged over the great
lady's handling of his departure the
washington free beacon reviewed a series
of postings to a facebook
group for current and former time
staffers where a tent's debate is
unfolding over mcniel's exit
one campus hurts that his dismissal was
justified in other asserts it said it's
a troubling
precedent which the new york times union
should have done more to prevent
whatever happens in the notion of worker
solidarity to giving a fellow worker the
benefit of the doubt asked steven
greenhouse who spent three decades
covering labor issues for the new york
times
why didn't the news guild that's the
union do far more to defend and protect
the job of a long-time times employee
one who at times did tireless heroic
worf work on behalf of the guild to help
improve pay and conditions for all new
york times employees
times crossword columnist deb amlin
accused greenhouse of an exclu of an
excessive focus on the
on the perpetrator arguing that he and
others should shift their attention to
the people mcneal had harmed
by the way there's no evidence that
mcneal actually harmed anybody he was
literally asked a question
about whether a person in high school
should be canceled for at 12 using the
n-word and he said
was the person saying bleep in the
context of a rap song or not
that is the sin that he was fired for
essentially
when asked about this deb amblin said
why is the focus on discussions like
this
almost always on the perpetrator's life
and not those who are harmed by his
actions
mcniel's ouster came nearly two years
after the incident that precipitated it
while chaperoning high school students
on a pricey trip to peru the science
reporter responded to a question from a
student about whether one of her
classmates should have been suspended
for using the n-word
in the process he uttered the offending
syllables himself an internal
times investigation found his judgment
wanting but stopped short of firing him
only after the daily beast published an
account of the incident thrusting it
into the public realm for the first time
was mcneil pushed out
we do not tolerate racist language
regardless of intent said dean baquette
we talked about this yesterday what an
absurd standard that is
and we're not going to look to the
intensive language if you say a racial
slur to say
the word bleep is bad and evil if you
say that but you say the word
that's racist language regardless of
intent which is nuts
nuts by the way the the pipeline for the
daily beast this is how the daily beast
works obviously
they have a reporter over there in
maxwell county whenever somebody in the
media
awoke staffer gets mad they email
maxwell towney maxwell towney then runs
a piece about how the work staffers are
mad the editors at the offending paper
start
start prostrating themselves before the
woke staffers and then the woke staffers
stomp on their neck that's the way this
process works
mcniel's resignation on friday and
bequette's post-hoc explanation
that intent doesn't matter renewed the
bitter debate among staff with reporters
warring with each other in public and
private says the free beacon
a times spokeswoman muddied the waters
further on sunday telling the free
beacon that racial epithets had no quote
place in the newspaper
the paper as the free beacon notes
printed the same epithet last week
in a magazine profile of princeton
classics professor don el padilla
peralta
even in ironic or self-mocking
quotations about a speaker's own group
in rap lyrics for example their use of
rhodes the worthy inhibition
against brutality and public discourse
said danielle rhodes ha
that was the spokesperson for the paper
she declined to say if that policy
extends to social media or other new
york times writers including nicole
hannah jones
and astad herndon have quoted the slur
so for example back in 2016 hannah jones
wrote larry wilmore did not say you did
it
my n word she said there's a linguistic
difference between the n word with an er
at the end
and the n word with an a at the end so
the washington free beacon asked hannah
jones whether
intense made a difference in her case
because of course this is the standard
she's been pushing
racist language doesn't require intense
if you say the n-word it is racist you
ought to be fired
she responded by posting the reporter's
inquiry including his cell phone number
on twitter
in direct violation of the website's
terms of service you think she's going
to be suspended
yeah i don't think so i don't think so
greenhouse argued staffers who went
after mcniel including hannah jones and
race reporter john elligan had their
priorities backward many of them he
wrote were quote far more willing to
sympathize with these privileged 15 and
16 year olds than with a long-time
colleague who has done much great work
for the times
over the years when one times reporter
posted a statement from a non-profit
literary organization called pen
calling mcniel's aster chilling elegant
the race reporter responded by accusing
him of racism quote you often wonder
what your white colleagues who are
lovely to your face
are actually thinking or saying about
you or people like you behind your back
what if they just think that you're a
schmuck
you personally not people like you in
terms of race but maybe like
you and people who act like you are
schmucks how about that because you are
apparently according to the free beacon
the lack of clear standards has
generated
frustration internally i don't think
anybody feels like we have any clarity
about what about what happened with this
incident or other alleged incidents
said one new york times reporter we
demand transparency of other people we
don't have it in our own processes but
this is the point
when it comes to the woke there is no
standard to meet
you understand there's no standard at
all there is no
neutral standard the point is the
changing standard the point
is that you can do everything right and
still have it come back and bite you
directly on the ass
that is the standard the standard is
will you do all the things they want you
to do at precisely the time they want
you to do it
and will you atone when they demand
atonement and then will they continue to
hold it over your head and if they do
you need more atonement that is the
standard because this has nothing to do
with ideological consistency
or even a consistent philosophy all this
has to do with is
sheer power nicole hannah jones has it
at the new york times and nobody who's
honest at the new york times does
it is that simple alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of the ben shapiro show coming up soon
the matt wall show airing at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you